Смуга перешкод, стрільба і тактичні військові прийоми.
Так у Києві протестували зразки жіночої польової форми.
А зробити це покликали журналісток українських та іноземних видань
разом із військовими. Зараз цю форму тестують у міноборони України.
Це дуже важко. І дуже добре, що є жіночі штани на мені.
Форма буде дуже активно на виснаження йти по тих всіх позиціях
на смузі перешкод, які будуть. І вже безпосередньо це і буде показувати
для вас всіх, що таке форма - чи вона тримається, чи вона рветься,
чи вона зручна.
Якщо вона незручна - вона обтяжує ваше пересування
і може не дати вам можливість швидко змінити позицію,
або ви можете зачепитися за будь-що.
По-друге, форма має бути захищена максимально від того,
щоб, якщо в разі буде якесь попадання артобстрілу і будуть якісь там
можливості загоряння її, вона не має горіти, вона не має тліти,
вона не має прилипати до шкіри людини.
Це стало зрозуміло одразу під час проходження мною перешкод.
Адже потрібно було стрибати, бігти, дертися на гору та лізти в окопі.
Це при тому, що ми долали перешкоди без додаткового навантаження,
на відміну від жінок на передовій.
Штани протестували. Якби на мені було три розміри більше
– я не уявляю, як перелазити в окопі. Я б просто напевно застрягала.
Ця форма пошита за спеціальними лекалами для жінок-військових.
А завдяки тканині ріп-стоп вона не горить, не промокає і не рветься.
Китель приталений, у штанах – спеціальна висока посадка,
є достатньо місця для стегон.
Під колінами є липучки, завдяки яким можна зробити штани довшими
чи коротшими. Такі ж липучки є на талії, щоб припасувати розмір під себе.
Жіноча тілобудова значно відрізняється від чоловічої.
В жінок зазвичай вужчі плечі, в жінок є талія, в жінок ширші стегна.
І це все потрібно враховувати при пошитті форми.
Насправді це про повагу, це про зручність та комфорт при виконанні
бойових завдань, бо ця війна чітко показала, що жінки їх можуть
виконувати й виконують на рівні з чоловіками на передовій.
Наша форма пошита з дуже якісної тканини.
Ця тканина відповідає всім стандартам Міністерства оборони.
Її склад 65% бавовни і 35% поліестеру. Внаслідок цього вона дихає.
Загалом у ЗСУ нині служить 60 тисяч жінок.
І їм досі видають чоловічу військову форму та білизну.
За виправлення цієї ситуації взялися волонтери.
Перші зразки форми, яку розробила ініціатива Arm Women Now,
випробували на передовій 4500 жінок-військових.
Серед них - Аліна, яка від початку повномасштабної війни
разом із сестрою приєдналася до лав ЗСУ.
У перші два місяці вони ходили взагалі без форми, а далі жінкам
почали видавати чоловічу, яку доводилося перешивати.
Це вже другий мій комплект. Він був супер зручним,
він пройшов зі мною бахмутський напрямок, дуже зручно, комфортно,
не обмежує в рухах, тому що талія підвищена, а чоловічі штани,
ви знаєте, вони такі, і вони спадали. Тут все зафіксовано,
ти мобільна, рухлива.
Це було б дуже чудово, якби всі жінки були забезпечені формою
всіх розмірів, тому що є різні розміри.
І вона тобі підійде потім в бойових умовах, і ти будеш комфортно себе
відчувати на бойових завданнях. Це дуже важливо.
Жіночу військову форму розробили за стандартами НАТО.
Проте її максимально адаптували до української статутної форми.
Коли ми пошили перший екземпляр форми, китель відрізнявся зовнішньо
від нашого статутного. Там були трішки інші кишені.
В формах НАТО не використовують застібки і липучки,
вони використовують ґудзики.
І, власне, ми намагалися адаптувати форму до українських реалій,
тому що в нас є свої вимоги, які передбачені наказами міністерства оборони.
Власне, вся форма була розроблена, враховуючи стандарти НАТО,
але і з побажаннями наших захисниць.
І кінець кінцем ми дійшли до того, що, наприклад, нагрудні кишені,
які є в нашій формі, які є в чоловічому українському однострої,
вони значно зручніші за ті кишені, які є на формі НАТО.
Тобто, наразі Україна, на жаль, вже має такий досвід,
яким вона може ділитися з країнами НАТО та іншими країнами
за їхнім бажанням, а не тільки брати чийсь досвід.
Міноборони вже схвалило і рекомендувало до впровадження жіночу
спідню білизну, виготовлену Arm Women Now.
Тепер на черзі – літня жіноча військова форма.
На мені літній польовий костюм у кольорі мультикам.
Такий же – у кольорі піксель – зараз знаходиться на фінальній стадії
затвердження у міністерстві оборони. І вже зовсім скоро така жіноча
уніформа може бути запроваджена для жінок-військових.
Усі лекала і розробки вже передали в міністерство.
На їхній основі там мають зробити зразок-еталон і провести тендер.
Далі почнуть відшивати жіночу військову форму і забезпечувати нею захисниць.
Країна, яка активно рухається до того, щоб вступити до Альянсу НАТО,
повинна працювати над тим, щоб в українській армії було
гендерно орієнтоване забезпечення, щоб кожна жінка почувалася
комфортно і була ефективною при виконанні бойових завдань,
тому що в першу чергу це повага до гідності жінок.